today on led live we'll be discussing a
sensitive topic that may be triggering
for some viewer discretion is advised
at the top in the bio of chesley's
instagram she says god first and so that
leads me to assume that she may have
been christian
where was god when she was on top of
that building
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
on january 30th chesley chris died after
falling from her new york city apartment
building it's reported that she took her
own life
we wanted to come on our platform today
to share our deepest condolences to her
family and the families of those who
have lost loved ones this way chesley
actually made history as the oldest
woman to be crowned miss usa in 2019.
she was also a licensed attorney and
served as a correspondent for extra
receiving two daytime emmy awards
nominations hey extra it's me chesley
crist miss usa welcome to atlanta and
the miss universe pageant now looking at
her life accomplishments it's it's
evidence how functional and successful
someone can be while still being
severely depressed
it's often a silent killer and a shock
to the people around them before the
virus self-deletion was the 10th leading
cause of death in the united states but
for ages 10 to 34 it's actually the
second leading cause of death there's a
rapid increase in helplessness that has
nothing to do with how beautiful or
accomplished or even how loved someone
is
life gets dark and it's gotten
increasingly difficult to cope
in the context of self-deletion the
people who cared about this person they
may feel this emotion of intense guilt
whether it is what they could have done
or maybe something they should not have
done
speaking about guilt is guilt a
beneficial emotion trying to cope with
this you know grief or is it actually a
harmful emotion
uh i think it can be a little bit of
both but i think it's more
i mean you can what if all day long you
know i had a daughter that passed away
she was special needs she stopped
breathing her sleep and we were
what if thing about everything what if
we use the cpap machine that actually
causes her to
vomit and could have choked on her vomit
and could have died a lot sooner you
know it's like there's all kinds of
things that you can toss around in your
mind and
[Music]
i don't think it's beneficial i think
it'll eat you alive but at the same time
it depends on what the guilt is about
i mean because you learn from
experiences as well
and if uh if there was maybe there was a
situation where somebody died and there
was something you could have done
and
i think that guilt is there
to help you learn from that and grow
from that
guilt i think is part of the coping
mechanism and it can be good for a
period of time but it can also lead to
depression it can lead to
to
major problems inside of of a marriage
inside of other relationships
particularly when it becomes
a
angry hateful because those are all
parts of the coping mechanisms but
but we shouldn't be sad or we shouldn't
be
angry at ourselves for being guilty we
should uh we should always be um
it's just part of the process of
grieving i think yeah i think guilt can
help people identify different things in
terms of like what could or should not
have been done and that can help
going forward how they interact with
people going forward but to kind of hold
yourself in the past something you can't
change that may be the issue and the
devil loves looking for any little
instance to pervade our thoughts to just
drive us insane and that's something
that can definitely happen if someone
stays in the past instead of seeing how
they can better themselves for the
future
yeah but it's not something i agree that
should be either suppressed or
you should feel bad for having a certain
emotion because at the end of the day we
are humans and we feel right and so but
depending on how long we feel that thing
that's when it can get
dangerous multiple popular artists have
actually come out and expressed the
depression that they've experienced in
their own lives one of them being justin
bieber i think that there was times when
i was really really suicidal like really
like man is this pain ever gonna go away
it was consistent the pain was so
consistent i was just suffering i had no
idea that this life would take me by
storm i had no idea that i would just
get sucked up by all this stuff there
was so many people who were just so mean
random people saying you suck you look
like a girl
and i would just shake it off and act
like it didn't bother me but that stuff
bothered me and it affected how i acted
and how i treated people and then it's
this ongoing cycle of hurt people hurt
people
so something that's interesting is that
so many times in
mainstream media and in our culture a
lot of like we say that we want this
lifestyle to be famous to have all this
money to be rich
and it's crazy because these very
artists are the ones that are coming out
and saying in their work that this life
is actually really hard it's not all
what it seems and they even put it in
their work he has a popular song that
came out recently it's called lonely by
um and he was the co-writer of it and so
i'll just read to you some of the like a
few of the stanzas from the lyrics and
just let me know what you guys think but
he says everybody knows my name now but
something about it feels strange
look like looking in a mirror trying to
steady yourself and seeing somebody else
and everything is not the same now it
feels like all our lives have changed
maybe when i'm older it'll all come down
but it's killing me now
what if you had it all but nobody to
call
maybe then you'd know me because i had
everything but no one's listening and
that's just lonely i'm so lonely
i want to call justin bieber right now
man what's up dude
i don't care about your money or nothing
man let's just kick it
yeah
there you know there were so many people
that came out
so many stars comedians that came out
people that are supposed to be happy and
funny they would come out and they would
say
the struggle is real right after rob and
william committed suicide
[Music]
i forget i forget the exact names of who
these people are but they they all said
look
we struggle with this
it's not all happiness
and you know i i gotta wonder if some of
it's spiritual warfare
because if you're if you're
dealing with some of these things
sometimes it
that comes back to haunt you
but
it goes to show you that money fame
doesn't bring happiness
right
and it reminds me of the bible verse
that actually um in
proverbs 13 7 it says a pretentious
showy life is an empty life a plain and
simple life is a full life
i've never even heard that before yeah
that's great that is exactly what it
reminded me of and it's crazy because
sometimes
you know like we know it's hard to come
forward about these issues but then
they're in songs that we're singing and
that are top hits and that have really
nice beats in the background that
sometimes distract you from the lyrics
right but it's like these are real like
they're telling you their story like
i am depressed you know i am sad i am
alone you know even though it looks like
i have
millions of people ordering tickets to
my show you know it's not what it seems
another artist that has come out about
this is billy eilish billy's experience
shows that no matter how good someone's
life seems like
it should be from the outside mental
health factors can still surface that's
why people who experience anxiety and
depression get frustrated when people
say things like what do you have to be
sad about or but you're doing so well in
this part of your life why just not
focus on that those questions aren't
helpful because mental health doesn't
always depend on career success or an
exciting
advancement in your personal life
someone can still experience a dark time
while it seems good things are happening
to them she also has another song it's
called listen before i go
and it says take me to the rooftop i
want to see the world when i stop
breathing turning blue tell me love is
endless don't be pretentious leave me
like you do
if you need me want to see me better
hurry because i'm leaving soon sorry
can't save me now sorry i don't know how
sorry there's no way out but down call
my friends and tell them that i love
them and i'll miss them but i'm not
sorry call my friends and tell them that
i love them and i'll miss them sorry
what are we going to do about those
words
right yeah and it could be from written
from her own personal experience i know
some some artists do draw from other
people's experience but nonetheless it's
an issue and it's a song that a lot of
people related to
and the sad part is
what if this is the last song you hear
and you and it's like yeah i'm going to
do it because she's not saying there's
any hopes he's like i'm done exactly
this is it like i don't want to be here
anymore i'm sorry there's a lot of
people defending her when we talked
about the song all the good girls go to
hell and they're like you know she's
helped me so much when i'm depressed i
listen to her and
all they're seeing is someone that can
identify a lot of us have been able to
identify with being sad or going through
something
but what's the answer what's the result
the end hope yeah and that's something
that i do hear in
contemporary christian music is like
jeremy camp his whole testimony was he
married this woman who was terminally
ill and and she ends up dying and he
wrote this song about all the pain he's
going through but then there's this
chorus that says he knows and it's
talking about how jesus knows all the
pain you're going through he's been
through it himself he's been through
being betrayed he's been through being
nailed to the cross by people who were
saying
amen to the things he was saying the day
before
and uh so yeah the hope is he knows he's
right there with you through all the
pain he's walked the suffering you know
i think it's a good point that there is
oftentimes when i was
going through a low part of my life i'd
listen to some of the sad music and i'd
go well it helps me
it doesn't help you unless
you have that hope right i mean you
gotta i mean even that one song when he
says
he knows he knows
how many songs like this one have none
of that said in the song right right and
how is that helping
get rid of that out of your life right
it's not
yeah when you listen one thing i'm
noticing is when anybody tells us
anything
pictures come into our minds even if we
don't realize it and it's the same thing
like if i'm going to be listening to
this song if i'm laying in bed i'm
imagining myself on a rooftop
like she says i'm literally watching the
whole story play out up into when i jump
when i say sorry
you know
and it's like what is that what is it's
like putting ideas in your head
you know you're sad and it's like that's
the only way out
another artist that has come out about
depression is demi lovato and she has
struggled with it for most of her life
and has been very vocal about it in a
today interview she said i've dealt with
depression and suicidal ideation since i
was about seven years old and that's
something i've been very vocal about
i've talked about it for years and so
today i don't take it lightly i easily
could have been someone that wasn't
having this interview today and so she
even says like the reason why she's so
vocal about it is because she knows that
it is a very serious issue and she
struggles with it and she says that she
really tries to encourage people through
her music to not seek permanent
solutions to temporary problems
and
i think
it can be encouraging to see
um
to have someone who is
very vocal that this is not just a
like a one-time thing it is something
daily and it's like every day you have
to show up even though it's hard but
it's possible you know there's not
there's there's not just one way out you
know
even though it can be hard to go through
it it's possible you know and there are
highs and lows like she even says life
ebbs and flows you know so it's like
there are really really high moments
that we have then they're really really
low ones but that's just life and we
have to just keep going through it
do you think god works
i don't want to give satan too much
credit but i i do you think god works
harder on some people than the others
because
does satan work harder in some people
than others you know where i'm going
with this yeah if you are a popular
person that has
major influence
would if you were satan if you were the
devil who would you go after the person
that was in the middle of the country
somewhere or someone that was in the
middle of becoming an influence of
everyone else right right and so
i i when i when i see people that that
put this stuff out and they they have a
major influence on on others i wonder
what are they saying
what are they saying in there what could
be what could be going on that maybe
maybe god is using them
but maybe i mean we are we are
struggling against not flesh and blood
yeah the powers and principalities of
darkness right right who knows so i
don't know that's my thoughts when that
comes around yeah so a few years ago
when i was in high school i
i experienced severe depression and i
also
was having suicidal thoughts and i was
just in a very dark place
i felt very alone i didn't really have
many friends i
was being bullied
and i just remember
just being so depressed sometimes that i
didn't even have
like just the energy to talk and it was
i was so i guess i felt so
fragile like you could ask me how are
you doing and i would just start crying
it was just a very sensitive time in my
life and i remember
just spending most of my days in my room
crying when i got back from school i
wasn't eating and i remember just going
to bed every single night and begging
god to take my life
and
every time i woke up the next morning i
was
so defeated i was so mad at him i was i
was saying like god why would you wake
me up like why do i have to go through
this all over again
and
i went through that for months and when
god finally did step in i i really
felt his presence in a way that i
didn't even know i could and i felt like
he personally saw me and just came down
to comfort me
and
i remember
i was going to school one morning
and i was waiting for the bus and when i
got on the bus there was this girl
who
she was
she came into the semester in a really
weird time no one should be coming
to school at this point like we've
passed midterms it's just not a good
time to
transfer to a new school at this point
and i remember i got on the bus and she
smiled at me and i had felt invisible
for so long i remember thinking like
what is wrong with this girl like why is
she looking at me like that
and
over time she ended up coming to sit
with me and talk with me and wanted to
be my friend and i remember
just
her being there for me encouraging me
there was even one time where
i didn't have anyone to sit with at
lunch so i would sometimes sit in the
library but i remember that she left her
class one time to come sit with me at
lunch in the cafeteria and that was a
way that i just always remembered god's
love and him it just felt like it was an
angel that showed up for me and he was
somewhere in heaven saying britney's
having a really hard time and i need one
of you guys to go down there and be with
her and i never forgot that experience
and she really helped me heal
through so much and
i i just i saw so much of god through
her and from that experience i became a
christian
i
i saw a glimpse of how good
god really is and it changed my life
completely while i was going through
that difficult time in my life i really
really held on to
one specific bible verse which it's
found in
psalms 34 18 and it says the lord is
close to the brokenhearted and saves
those who are crushed in spirit
and i
held on to that verse
every single day since i discovered it
because it really reminded me that god
does not expect us to be happy all the
time he knows that life on earth is
going to be hard jesus's life on earth
was hard but yet he's saying that he
totally understands and he sees and he
is there for us and with us when we're
in times that are dark and where it
feels like
he's not there and that he really is you
know jesus had something to say about
this very thing in luke chapter 21. now
the context of that chapter is
foreshadowing the destruction of
jerusalem in 70 a.d but we can apply the
same principles today in luke chapter 21
we find jesus in the treasury of the
temple speaking of the hardships to come
and the things that he lists out would
make anyone question the value of life
but then he says in the midst of all of
that look up
help is on the way and just as jesus
provided a place of refuge for believers
back then
he's doing the same today
unpopular opinion right this is
interesting christians are unhealthily
obsessed with escapism
what is escapism
it's the tendency to seek distraction
and relief from unpleasant realities
especially by seeking entertainment or
engaging in fantasy
do you guys agree or disagree
oh i agree that people do do that and
it's a sad thing because i think jesus
is supposed to be our escape
lay your burdens upon him i mean he
promised that we'd have tribulation
people are going to hate us all these
things and maybe it's just a lot easier
these days to have you know pull out
your phone
whereas a couple hundred years ago you
didn't have so much media saturation it
wasn't like you could just go to the
store and get a beer or whatever you
probably had to make it yourself you
know
everything's just so easily accessible
now that it's like
i'm hurting
i want to escape this pain
uh god you're kind of my last resort
because this is easier right now and i i
think we do that
a lot i notice that we try to do things
in our own power until it basically
chews us up and spits us out and then
we're like okay god you're my last
resort yeah and he's like man i'm
supposed to be your first resort
it's a very sad state
a verse comes to mind um the bible talks
about god providing an escape that's in
first corinthians chapter 10 i believe
verse 13. but i think that text is kind
of misused sometimes because um
god providing an escape or us escaping
doesn't mean that we don't deal with the
problem
and a story that comes to mind you guys
remember when jesus first proclaimed
himself as the son of god he was in the
synagogue and the jewish leaders didn't
like that very much and they kind of
like
ambush him in a way pushing him trying
to push him off the cliff and then he
what's the word is it teleports or
translates to someplace else
it's in the bible yeah yeah when they're
about to throw him off the cliff right
yeah yeah and he goes somewhere else but
he didn't stop his ministry because of
that he didn't run away from the jews
because of that he faced his problem
head-on
but in that instant of danger god
providing provided him a way of escape
and i think that's a more accurate uh
that's putting it back in its context in
a more accurate interpretation where god
protects his people in various different
ways as well we can't put our own
um ideas on how god decides to protect
his people but we should face the the
problem face the temptation and get to
the root of it
and not agree look for what is it
escapism entertainment or engage in
fantasy to distract from unpleasant
realities because we're living in an
unpleasant reality and it's it's
something we have to deal with with that
though can also come
you have to ask the question why do
people go to these and usually it's
because they feel like they can't talk
to someone about it so then you know
because if you feel like you're alone
or like no one's listening to you then
all you have left are these escapism
type of realities you know to cope with
it and so i think that could be another
factor is if you lack that supportive
community it's like you feel like you
have nowhere else to go accept
you know to some unhealthy escapism yeah
route
if you don't have that community i think
that's the biggest one of the biggest
challenges we have today we have
a difficulty
that's going around in our in our
realm
a type of
fouchy algae that's happening
and it's causing everyone to seclude
themselves from everyone right and when
that happens it causes
us to communicate less us we don't go to
our neighbor and look over the fence and
say hey how are you doing even though
you might be of a different denomination
might be a different church might be of
a different
political persuasion
we need that we need that communication
that's face-to-face
ism so that we can be better rounded
people and communicate better with
people
yeah the bible says
forsake not the assembly you know
because
it's easy when you're isolated i've
heard this uh analogy like if you have a
a fireplace full of coals burning it's
it's raging it's flaming but then you
pull one coal out and it's burning and
you set it on the on the ground it just
goes out fizzles out but then you put it
right back in that
you know that community again and it
flames right back up
you know it's the week will just drain
you you'll get faced with all kinds of
tribulations
and then that weekly
at least once a week time when you
gather together and you're around other
believers you can lift each other up
pray for each other hey how you guys
doing instead of putting on a fake smile
and saying oh you know everything's
great
we should be more open and transparent
so actually
i really would could appreciate i really
appreciate it if you pray with me about
this that's going on in my life right
now i think too often we think no i'm
supposed to be happy here you know i'm
supposed i got to put on this good front
even though we were just
arguing in the parking lot or you know
i'm dealing with this thing
i can't let people know at church that i
drink or whatever i'm struggling with
this thing pornography or whatever these
are like
embarrassing shameful things but that's
the place you need to be transparent
about those are the people who are
connected to god and who uh you know
this part of their ministry has brothers
and sisters in christ to
uh pray you through that
but oftentimes either
that person this is the problem with the
church either those people don't really
care to know how you're doing and you
start unloading on me like oh well
everyone's really trying to walk out of
here or you're not going to be
transparent and i'm not going to know
the problem anyway
i think there's a lot of value in
checking up on people yeah that is
something that i feel like
we don't do enough anymore um and you
know we just get so caught up in our own
lives you know we're busy you know
especially as you start getting into an
adult
um
but yeah i think there's a lot of power
and value in that especially because
right now on social media there's a lot
of like self-care culture and in terms
like yes it's good important to take
care of yourself but i i see it a lot of
times swayed to the selfish side where
it's like i'm going to take care of me
first i don't care what's going on in
your life i come first you know and it's
like well if you're always thinking
about you all the time where do i come
in you know what if i need you to help
me through something and you're not
there and then people start to kind of
close themselves off because they feel
like nobody cares
so i think there's
that's definitely something that's
undervalued it's just the power of
checking up on people and saying hey i
thought of you today how are you doing
you know and actually waiting to hear
the answer or actually creating that
space where if they say i'm really
struggling then it wasn't like a
you're just gonna pass it by but you're
just actually going to sit down and hear
um what they have to say
i completely agree
and
i've a lot of stuff happened to me in
the past couple months like a lot of
painful things
and uh it could be overwhelming when i
open up my messenger and there's
all these people and i know
every one of them are just saying you
know i'm sorry i'm praying for you and
stuff
um
but don't give up because there is a
tendency to kind of seclude yourself
from people like i just need to deal
with this you know or
or
that person is seeking someone who's
been there
i know for me it was like
i got to a point where i was like i
don't want to hear you're sorry and
you're praying for me i need to talk to
somebody who's been there who's been on
who's on the other side of this thing
and can tell me and for a while those
were the only people i would talk to but
now i'm going through those messages and
i'm like
wow thank you for checking up on me but
use different forms too like
don't just use messenger because it
could be flooded yeah call you know call
or text make it even more personal the
next step because
i actually
i haven't even been to my home church
yet because it's like i just don't want
a hundred people saying how are things
going and have to say the same thing to
each person
but
individuals from church have called me
and i've had great conversations with
them and i'm thankful that they called
me because it's just one-on-one i don't
have to be surrounded by a bunch of
people so
yeah i agree and use different forms
yeah and just think about the ideas that
float in people's minds when people want
to take their own lives it's something
that is not easy right you know like
people often think oh
you know they associate it with someone
going to hell or that being super
selfish and it's like if people already
have those ideas in their minds how can
you say
hey i'm so depressed that i don't want
to be here anymore
you know if someone says why especially
in her case
just think about someone saying why
you're so beautiful and you have all
this and this and that and you have
things that um everybody like prays for
you're living like the dream but it's
like you can't look at what the person
is producing in their life you have to
look at the person that's right you know
so there's a couple things here i want
to go back to what you were saying about
the church your church family and how
they've been reaching out to you
the church is made up of people right
and right throughout my life i've just
i've seen people try their best in very
different ways
and sometimes it's not even that the
church isn't trying it's that it's not
being received well
and i don't know why whether it's people
expect the church to fail or whatever
the case growing up we had um youth
events on saturday afternoons and there
would be a plethora of different topics
but these wouldn't show up or the
parents wouldn't bring the youth to the
the church on the saturday afternoon to
engage in these conversations it's not
that it wasn't happening it wasn't that
it was that the reception wasn't
wasn't i mean there wasn't good
reception towards it
um but on the other side like a positive
is yes when the church is made up of
people and people are doing what they
need to do such as picking up the phone
and calling maybe
in a case where someone doesn't really
want human interaction people just go
and leave food on their doorstep
and a note
alex our co-worker he lost his house
that was a really sad situation and
someone gave his family a dog and that
was a good emotional support wow and
they still have the dog today and you
know it's a blessing for them so there's
so many different ways to connect with
someone
aside from just sending them a message
or calling them if those don't work
there are other creative ways and i
think learning the
love languages learning the
um
i guess characteristics so the
personalities of the people within the
church will help us relate more to those
people when they're really in their time
of meet
in their time of need
i think relatability is the important
thing because you can easily
um
i know the church sometimes does have
this thing where it's they say kind of
some cliche things or some things that
aren't practical so it's like if you're
having dark thoughts pray to jesus about
it and he'll lift that up
okay
and if he doesn't if you struggle
through it like not everybody's
testimony is just
and you're done you know and you're
everything is crystal clear god took
everything away and you never have to
deal with it again not everybody's story
is like that so i think being able to
relate to someone and knowing using
wisdom through the holy spirit to know
what to say and what not to say because
sometimes just show jesus instead of
just you know tell people you know the
bible says that um sometimes the world
will give you trouble but god is much
bigger than any of your problems right
and so when we have troubles in our life
we need to
recognize that god is there and even
though um he might not take those things
away immediately
we
it might be for our trial that we go
through
prayer is still going to be involved you
could get other people involved in your
life to have prayer and sometimes those
people in your life might be the ones
that are drawing you down right so you
need to find a crowd of people that will
that will lift you up and get you out of
that
that funk that you're in right
right yeah in the bio of chesley's
instagram it says god first which leads
me to assume that she may have been
christian
where was god when she was on top of
that building you know where was god
when she may have been in a dark space
in the years prior to building up to
that
people who deal with these very intense
emotions leading them to self-harm with
the intention of taking their life where
is god
god's definitely right there with her i
mean she might have felt
disconnected
for many different reasons i mean
yeah it's hard to know what she was
really dealing with to drive her to that
point but
i think that god works mostly
through his people he wants us to have
his character and so it really makes me
question where was everybody else
where was god's people
to talk to her and really
make her feel valued and
like some of the stuff you were talking
about
people reaching out and stuff
there's two different ways to do it i
think sometimes you just need to be
there just let them talk i mean
you might feel unequipped or whatever
but
just let them talk man just sometimes it
just helps to have somebody there and
then if the person doesn't want to talk
then
that's when you can have a chance to
let them know how much they're valued
find positive things about them like
i can't imagine life without you in it
like you made my life so happy like
remember that time when you did this for
me like you don't have no idea how much
that
you know impacted my life
bring to remembrance how much value
their existence is you know yeah and i
think that's a huge way that god works
is through his people right
even jesus went through suicide i mean
if you read in the bible it says cast
yourself down and and throw yourself on
the rocks because the bible says you
will not
cast you're not hurt your feet on a
stone right
i'm paraphrasing but um
even even god thought you know what yeah
if i throw myself down here
is that true absolutely not satan was
misquoting the bible i'm sure that he
uses every single type of way to get
people to take their own life yeah and
uh yeah
and from from personal experience too
this was not a one-time situation she
could have been thinking this for maybe
a year right maybe two years
and
i do believe that god was present
because i know for me
i mean
every single day is a battle at this
point so she said yes to all the days
prior to this i'm going to stay i'm
going to choose to be here but it just
so happened on this day
whatever could have happened
it just really set her off you know i
don't think that means
that jesus wasn't there i believe that
he was but maybe
i don't know sometimes like
if you've just been dealing with
something for so long it really just
gets so over like you're tired you're
really worn out and god does respect our
choices
um and he understands where each of us
are i think what we would like for jesus
to do in these situations is to
literally
show himself and to stop being invisible
you know to stop speaking in a small
still voice when we're that deep in what
feels like hell
but
yeah it's just
i don't know that's that's a really
tough question
it really is tough
and
in a way i like that there isn't just
one answer because god is such a
personal being he shows up to each
person the way that oh yeah they will
recognize him
if they allow themselves to right yeah
there's a question a lot of christians
and others have
will people who took their life be in
heaven
that's a tough question too because i
mean
we look at the bible as uh
i don't know too many suicides or
i don't know too many uh
incidences where somebody took their own
life in the bible
i'm thinking of
saul after he went to the witch of endor
threw himself on the sword but i don't
he's jesus i think he really had yeah
judas
yeah saul
was already walking away from god
judas betrayed god and it says that
satan even entered into him i mean he's
a no-go but people like samson
you know it seemed like
near the end there he kind of had a
redemption type thing and he
kamikaze had pulled down the
the towers or the pull down the pillars
and the whole buildings fell on
everybody yeah including him yeah but
he's even mentioned in as god some of
god's mighty men even later on
so people have a big debate this is
actually a big theological debate about
samson because
you're absolutely right
he he he killed himself
but
we don't know exactly what his mindset
was before he died and so that's why
people are always tiptoeing around this
topic particularly because
sometimes you have
parents that have had kids that taken
their life we don't know what that kid
thought about before he died and how he
regretted what he wanted
but at the same time
taking your life is murder
and so it's a dangerous dangerous
dangerous thing to do and and god
winks at our sins committed and
ignorance that talks about an axe and
i'm i'm thinking interesting what if
somebody is
they're just so done with this world and
they're like lord and they really have a
relationship with god and they're just
like
i can't take this anymore i'd rather
just be with you right now and just do
it and if
if that's their mindset and they really
don't know what they're doing and
they're just so done
i mean there's got to be grace for that
you know is it that
you so you think it kind of boils down
to intention
because when you think of sam um saul
saul and judas they were
doing escapism they're like oh i can't
handle this right and they did what they
did
versus
samson or maybe a parent who sees a car
coming and just goes and does something
and they end up
dying but their child lives well i
definitely think self-sacrifice is much
different i mean jesus said no one takes
my life except i lay it down and he says
that uh
you know a true friend is someone who
lays down his life for his friends or
true love is
someone who's not his own life but he's
not doing it to himself i mean he knows
what's coming
um it's self-sacrifice and that's the
deepest love you could have that's yeah
i mean if you do that for your child or
something like you're gonna be rewarded
for that because you
gave up yourself over someone else so
that may be two completely different
things but i remember uh scotty he
watched a documentary about people who
jumped off the golden gate bridge which
survived so you know they live to tell
what did it feel like like when you were
standing there what were you going
through and then when you jumped and
then on the way down and then when you
you know the whole experience
um a lot of them said
as soon as they stepped off the bridge
the second wow
immediately regret or what am i doing oh
god save me or i'm sorry
and there's two points to that one god
hears even in that moment and going back
to what you were saying we don't know
what the person was thinking or
struggling through or what happened
right before their life ended god says
come unto me all your weary i will give
you rest i will be there sins are
forgiven and you know i i'm not anyone
to say but going off the bible they
would be in heaven right they'll be
saved
um but also
just someone experiencing that it's
almost as if
satan is there torturing and torturing
and then finally when the person jumps
off he's like okay mission accomplished
and he takes a step back and in that
moment of clarity they're finally like
lord save me
and and he does you know isn't that
amazing yeah and that's brings
validation to the point with that god is
always there he's just standing right
there by you waiting for you to open the
door of your heart and he will he will
come in that's like the thief on the
cross type scenario you know like in
that last moment
and and christ said you'll be with me so
it
you know it's not something that we
recommend waiting until you're on your
deathbed to give your heart to god
but he is there even in the final
moments and think about the time i mean
the flesh is weak and think about the
times that somebody just pushes your
buttons enough that you just oh you snap
and you
immediately regret the way you yelled at
your child or whatever because they just
push your buttons enough
that same thing could be the scenario
when you're on that bridge and you're
like
i'm done and you make that decision out
of a knee-jerk reaction but immediately
regret it
gotcha yeah i i
i understand exactly what you're saying
and what's interesting is in the bible
moses who led israel for a number of
years
struggled and struggled with
hate he struggled with with
with being angry with people the whole
time right he killed that egyptian he
was he was upset um
there was something else he was upset
about the garage yeah
in the end he struck the rock and said
look what israel what we have to bring
to you and god said all i want you to do
is speak to the rock and he struck it
and he because he was absolutely upset
with him well he disobeyed god and god
said
god the bible says
god and satan struggled over his
his salvation
because he they because at one
he the last thing he did
he wasn't supposed to do that so he
wasn't supposed to see the promised land
the promised land is a
a type of our salvation yeah
and so god said look you can't
see this promised land
but throughout your entire life you have
followed me
and for that reason you will see
heaven and he took him he took his body
struggled with satan over it but he took
his body saying no this is my this is my
soul so i love this quote there's a
quote uh that i can't recite word for
word but it's a commentary that says
our
our salvation
isn't doesn't come down to just one
event it doesn't come down to just a
single thing that we do but it's a
culmination of a life
living our life either according to god
or according to satan
and
we have to be on that it's basically an
addiction are we addicted to god or are
we addicted to something in this life
that is not of god
wow that's uh that's hopeful you know to
think about that you're not gonna be
your whole
relationship with god is not gonna end
over this one little thing you know
right really this whole once saved
always saved
debate or whatever it's not
based on like well where's the line so i
can tow it the whole time it's i'm in
love with jesus and i don't want to do
anything that hurts him but if you start
willfully going against
his commands and his word and what you
know is right then you're choosing to
walk away from that relationship
just because he walked down the aisle
and said i do
doesn't mean that you're in a loving
relationship if that day you go
move off with some other woman and live
with her
you know it's not it's not an act it's
not one time event like i said that
little prayer and now i'm kingdom bound
no it's a relationship and i think
everyone agrees that salvation is
relationship not religion not legalism
not works based yeah but when you'll
know them by their fruits like
if your fruit is
i'm willfully disobeying constantly then
you're not in a relationship with jesus
yeah and i think it's important to
remember too that god
is doing everything he can to make sure
that we get to heaven like when i look
at in the old testament how they had to
do all these rituals
you know to then jesus coming and dying
and it's like we know like he told the
woman at the well you no longer have to
go to like
these holy cities to pray you can
literally just come to me in spirit and
in truth like you don't have to do all
these big travels you know and
it's like he he really does try to make
it easier on us to choose him but it
does ultimately come down to
um
our
our decisions but it's comforting to
know that
there are parts of people's lives that
god sees that we
make that we've never seen you know
and
he takes those into account you know but
it's like that is comforting that just
one act does not determine
you know a whole person's life
we've been really practical on what the
church what people in church can do if
they see someone who's struggling but
what about ourselves you know the
christian life
ain't easy
how can what can we do what can someone
do someone who may be watching what
think what can they do to keep from
being overwhelmed
to then that might lead to something bad
you know
a community yes
okay yeah reach out man you can reach
out to us i mean we're here i've i've
talked to people on the phone for hours
i mean ministry doesn't
stop when we turn the cameras off or
when we clock out you know it's like
it's
i drive home and i'm talking to somebody
you know okay
that's that's an
amazing one that's
but uh if you try to reach out and the
person doesn't pick up the phone you're
there with yourself and your thoughts
what can someone do prayer
i think i think it's important to
surround ourselves with things
that we know
um
that
that kind of grounds us in happiness or
joy that reminds us of good things
but they're about ourselves like i know
for me i really enjoy when people write
me handwritten letters so i know there's
this one um
this one
birthday card that my mom gave me i mean
she usually people throw those away but
to me those are very sentimental and she
was just like i'm so proud that you're
my daughter and all this stuff and i
saved that you know and just to to have
these remnants of things that bring you
joy or photographs and your happiest
moments and
and things to just remind you that there
are reasons to stay and
um yeah prayer is a good one um
even
if all you do is look up on google
bible verses for depression my favorite
is
in psalms where it says god is close to
the brokenhearted that was one verse
that i really really held on to just to
know that
god is not saying
you know you're not a real christian if
you're not happy all the time because
that's what we make it seem like we make
it seem like it's not going to be hard
but to know that god understands that we
are humans and we will experience
brokenness he's saying i'm going to be
there and he also says cast all your
fears and anxieties
on him you know and he's telling us we
can come to him for everything it's not
just ignore your feelings and come
worship me it's bring all that you are
to me and i'm there
it says be anxious for nothing but in
all things by prayer supplication
thanksgiving thank god for what he's
doing in your life even if you don't see
it happening
and that the peace of god which
surpasses all understanding will guard
your hearts and minds i'm trying to
think of a situation where
somebody just really doesn't have
anybody it's hard for me to think about
because i've
always had family i've always had
friends and well you did bring out um
don't ignore your feelings i think
that's an excellent point because um one
thing i would say is don't procrastinate
on um getting to the root of why you
feel a certain type of way
and so when it comes to overwhelm well
why are you overwhelmed are you doing a
bunch of stuff in terms of outreach but
you're giving from an empty cup do you
need to step back for a second do you
need some self-care do you need to study
the word um do you just need a nap
you know or a good plate of food instead
of fast food like
these little things can add up to a big
benefit to that point i mean all these
are fantastic but some things even
outside of this can add to the ability
to to help you like just getting outside
need to get outside you need to get some
sunshine that's right you need to go on
you need to get some exercise get those
endorphins in your in your body you will
automatically feel better at least a
little bit if you get out and you
exercise a little bit fresh air
water make sure your water intake's good
i mean all these things contribute to
how you feel inside and so it's not
always just a spiritual thing but it's
all also
a physical thing
and a mental thing because physical it's
physical
right what you put into your body feeds
your mind your mind is an organ itself
and that's where mental health comes in
into play but i was i was thinking about
somebody that just doesn't have any
where to turn if they really don't have
anywhere to turn and you really think
this could be your last day or whatever
like
why don't you go do something nice for
somebody you know like we we've talked
about on this show like
the people who have the longest happiest
lives or those who
work in
some kind of like nursing like where
they're taking care of other people
so it's like yeah that adds value to
yourself so if you have no one else and
nobody else is going to take care of you
why don't you be that person why don't
you be christ and go out to that
homeless person and give them some food
and some money and encouragement yeah
and see how it makes you feel take the
focus off yourself right put it on
someone else and then you will forget
about all your woes i mean even if it
comes down to just going out and petting
a puppy that's what i was going to say
because those with anxiety that might be
really intense to try to go find someone
and help another human being right but a
pet a plant just keeping a plant alive
you know you have to open those shades
let the sun in at least for the plants
benefit and you yourself get benefit as
well
it it involves some effort for sure it
does and there should be prayer
throughout each proc each step of this
process yeah that was excellent that's
excellent advice yeah i really do think
it's important to get out of here
of your own head because i remember um
on the puppy topic because i had i had a
pet growing up
um
and
i remember when
when she passed away
um and it like you know my mom like
me and my brother were out off to
college so we weren't home and my mom
was like man i really underestimated how
this dog helped me um
you know get out of the house because i
had to take her for a walk you know so i
had to actually get out of the house and
so
it's like yeah those little things like
having a pet or something really does
help and
and they're so gracious too like it's
like they're just so they're such gentle
lovers yeah you cry they lick your tears
and everything they're they're really
comforting and they don't require
like you to talk to them really it's
just or like there's this doesn't
require conversation it's just presence
and sometimes that really is what you
need
i'll leave you with three c's
clarity
community and christ
clarity you know it's the devil's goal
to cloud the mind
there's a direct correlation between
addiction whether media drug or sex
related and depression
what door may be open that's letting in
all that smoke clouding your mind or or
masking the problem
our thoughts wield greater control over
our mood than our circumstances
community now the very things people on
the outside looking in regard as
privileges
well those could be the same things that
are a heavy burden for the person
experiencing depression
things like being intelligent beautiful
or famous all of these could actually be
very isolating
anxiety
distress or or overwhelm it can build up
to dark thoughts
a great counter to this is a solid
community support accountability
relatability and love and most
importantly the opportunity to serve
all of these things can be found in
community
christ
thomas in despair
he asked jesus lord
we don't know where you're going so how
can we know the way and i love jesus's
answer he simply says
i am the way
i am the truth and i am the life
remember
look up
help is on the way
hey guys thanks for joining us today if
you are someone who has been struggling
with this feel free to check out the
resources in the description below and
also make sure that you check us out on
facebook instagram and twitter and if
you feel impressed
feel free to support us on patreon
see you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
you